might as well just get rid of the the
helmet at this point like that's my
issue is okay if you want to build this
emotional thing that's fine but
logically from the from the from the
person we know as Master Chief in the
Halo and I love the people that said
this is their interpretation well their
inter interpretation sucks they're like
logically from what we've known of
Master Chief throughout the years his T
he's a tactician he's a he's very
strategic he's he's he's extremely like
inition when it comes to combat you mean
to tell me he going to fight with no
helmet on just out like that like that
makes no sense this is what they say
this is Pablo sh his IG article who
plays massach Chief he said um why
explain why massach Chief doesn't always
wear his helmet he said you're not going
to be able to bring an audience along in
a long form story without having access
to the character's face which tells you
what they're feeling how they think
about everything